[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored a
world exclusive interview from Beverly
Hills in California where I sit down
with a woman who right now is probably
the most famous woman on planet Earth
Stormy Daniels was the biggest porn star
in the world 17 years ago when she met
and had a one-night stand she says with
Donald Trump then the biggest TV
business star in the world
well that one night stand this week led
to Donald Trump appearing in a court in
Manhattan New York where he became the
first American president in history to
ever face criminal charges those charges
relate to alleged hush payments made for
Stormy Daniels to stop her telling her
story well tonight she tells me a story
foreign
[Music]
Stormy Daniels do I call you stormy yes
I'm happy for that for an interview
absolutely it's Miss Daniels if you're
nasty
you've I mean you're probably right now
the most famous woman on planet Earth
how does that how does that feel
terrifying does it yeah and surreal it
just doesn't make sense
everyone thinks they know you very few
people I guess know you properly
what has it been like for you to go
through this extraordinary political
Maelstrom
um there's like so many facets to that
answer I mean it was completely shocking
at first you know I was pretty
established I had my fan base I was well
known in the adult industry I had been a
contract star for a long time you know
both as a performer writer director all
of that stuff and I had really
solidified my place and where I wanted
to be there so there was this like
instant explosion
but my fan base switched like the people
that had been my followers my fans for
the longest time were a completely
separate demographic than the ones I was
totally being
you know swarmed with you know I was
dancing in strip clubs which I had
always done but used to be I go on stage
and most of the people would be you know
white guys in suits very much like you
and then suddenly overnight I walked out
on stage and all of those guys were gone
and it's
gay men and trans people and women a lot
of women really just this whole other
crowd and dynamic so that was you know I
guess Shell Shocked would be the thing
and um and then just the misconceptions
and the shock that came with that you
know I had been in porn for a long time
I had a thick skin I wasn't surprised by
being called like you know sled or
you know all of that stuff but it was
the
being treated inhuman like next level
which was really really shocking and
then that narrative started to change
and people started to call me like
really crazy things like a hero and like
this Champion for the me two minutes so
then I started to feel like I was being
pulled in all of these different
directions where people
sometimes on purpose sometimes
inadvertently we're trying to use me to
fit their cause and their narrative and
what they wanted to get out of it you
know and that was never the case I was
just telling the truth what I've been
struck by is a lot of women I know
actually quite high profile women have
they find you very admirable they think
that you've actually grown to represent
female empowerment the way you stood up
to power the way you've refused to back
down the way you fought your corner and
the way you've defended your industry
where many people have as you say tried
to sort of dehumanize you and shame you
for and you've had none of that right
has that been nice for you to see a lot
of women actually come around and now be
on your side oh yeah absolutely
especially you know people
who work in the adult industry you know
that was a big deal for me there was all
these misconceptions that people in our
industry either work in that business
because they can't do anything else
because they're too stupid to do
anything else or they're broken or
they're you know failed at mainstream
actresses or whatever I'll tell you
right now that some of the smartest
women I've met have been in the adult
industry you know
um so that's really cool to sort of see
us taken a little more seriously
um and the you can't really shame
somebody who's
been seen naked everywhere like what are
you gonna do release nudes of me
please do good for business right
so Donald Trump yesterday became the
first former president of the United
States to ever be arrested to sit in a
courtroom facing criminal charges did
you watch it
um a little bit yeah it was on I mean it
was on every channel so I try not to pay
too much attention because it just
starts to like the gravity of the
situation and it has nothing to do with
Trump and it has nothing to do with
stormy but like when you look at it as a
whole like this is really happening in
our country and no matter if it goes in
his favor or you know my favorite
Democratic Republic it's it's gonna just
be more divisive and it's you know at
first I thought I'd be really excited
you know I thought that when that day
came because I didn't think it would and
then I really didn't think it would you
know
um I thought he was going to get away
with not being held accountable so when
I found out that it was coming or
potentially coming I thought that I
would feel excited and Vindicated
but it was kind of anti-climactic was it
how interesting yeah when you saw him in
the court what did you feel
um
part of me was you know finally like he
had to go in and be under the rule of
someone else he had to obey the the
judge and walk through like a you know
the King has been dethroned he's no
longer Untouchable
um and nobody should be Untouchable it
doesn't matter if what your job
description is whether you're the
president like
um you should be held responsible for
your actions but the other side of it
was like this is someone that our
country elected and chose was there no
better option right you know I mean like
this is just
honestly if I there's a range of
emotions but I think sad was the one
that was
the most impactful and shocking for me
how weird is it you'll still me Daniels
and you had a perfectly nice life really
until recently with all this sort of
mayhem
and suddenly there's this moment in
American history and it's happening in a
courtroom and it's only really happening
because of you I mean if you chart back
the Genesis of his court case if he
hadn't through his lawyer which is what
the allegation is paid this money to you
he wouldn't be sitting there right and
that's a lot you know
um a lot of the nasty messages and stuff
I get really feel like it's my fault
that you know that I've made America the
laughingstalker I'm the fall of
democracy I wish I had that much power
but well you're only your only crime it
seems to me is you well you got paid 130
000 and someone's going to explain why
you got paid that I mean right which I
didn't even realize the gravity of the
situation at the time or you know the
repercussions of that but you know I'm
not responsible for all of us
bad behavior or the charges against him
by any stretch I mean I'm sure there's
this more than we can even imagine I
think he even goes on trial in a couple
weeks for rape it's not my I didn't I'm
not the fire I was the spark that Lit
the fuse that blew up the keg do you
think that this is the right fuse to
light putting aside your own feelings
about it or what's happened to you there
is an argument that I've seen this
actually from media across the Divide
really liberal meter as well so I don't
think there's enough there to justify
putting a former president through this
process
do you think I mean you've touched on
this but do you think it's healthy for
America and democracy to go after Donald
Trump over this particular thing or
would it have been better to wait for
what some would argue or the more
serious things January 6th the Georgia
phone calls uh the possession of
potential classified documents and so on
so I haven't to be completely honest I
haven't read the indictment or I have no
legal knowledge of it
um but I agree with you to me those are
such more significant crimes you know
what I mean my thing is one person and
obviously it's the most important thing
to me because I am me and it's selfish
you know my selfish
opinion but those
I mean the January 6th look how many
people got injured or you know what I'm
saying like it just seems like
that's a bigger thing but if this is
what leads to it I can't help but wonder
if
there's something we don't know right
well they haven't there is a belief they
may not have put everything into them
yeah what was already in a public domain
so we're gonna have to wait and see
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury but you may be asked to
testify if this ends up as a trial how
do you feel about potentially testifying
in the a child will be watched around
the world
um I mean anytime you're
up in the public eye it's scary I mean I
used to get scared giving oral book
reported school so I mean it's daunting
but I look forward to it you know what I
mean because
I have nothing to hide I'm the only one
that has been telling the truth and
you know you can't shame me any of them
more so
I feel like if they don't
it Paints the picture that they know
something about me that makes me
you know untrustworthy or not reliable
um so you want to have it I do I do I
think having them call me in and put me
on the stand
legitimizes my story and who I am and if
they don't it almost feels like they're
hiding me and people will automatically
assume I would that oh that she must not
be a good witness she's not credible
like so there's no doubt if they ask you
to testify you will testify oh
absolutely
you told the Times newspaper in London
last week I've seen him naked there's no
way he could be scarier with his clothes
on valid
it was a funny line
and true I stand by it
do you want to see him jailed I mean not
necessarily for this particular
indictment but just generally would it
give you any kind of closure with your
time involving Donald Trump to see him
in jail
my case I don't think his
crimes against me or
worthy of incarceration I feel like the
other things that he has done if he is
found guilty
absolutely because
a bigger problem is that if these
allergy Asians against him or whatever
else that we don't know yet he is found
guilty or the evidence suggests that he
is or whatever and he doesn't
that it's going to just basically I mean
it opens the door for other people to
to think they can get away with doing
that and worse one of the problems with
this particularly actually the
indictments involving you and Karen
McDougall who's the other woman who
received a payoff
become very politically toxic because
Republicans and I understand this they
say look it's different rules for Donald
Trump to what it's been for Democrat
politicians and they say John F Kennedy
John Edwards Bill Clinton all had
similar scandals some far worse none got
indicted that there seems to be a
political bias there
that's one way of looking at it another
way of looking at it because if you want
to look at the positive in this is that
we have made progress you know in our
justice system in our country and and
for women you know what I mean like if
that those other presidents had done
today what happened then would it be
treated the same or is it specifically
just people screaming this is a vendetta
against Trump but let's for a moment
here pretend that it was another
president or Clinton today and this
happened I mean look how I think that's
right post post me too exactly I think
there probably would have been actually
a different attitude to a lot of these
former Democrat politicians that's what
I hope and believe you know what I mean
like people just trashed Miss Lewinsky
and and you know all the way back
through history and
I would like to believe that if those
things happen now that
it would be different of course he's
going to spin it and the Republicans and
the Maga people are going to spin it and
say like it's just because it's him but
is it really you know what I mean like
I'm hoping that it's just us moving
forward and you could apply that to you
know the way that's
you know racial crimes or handles or you
know what I'm saying like I just think
that it's hopefully a sign of progress
and I see everybody whoever you are have
a powerful you should be held
accountable oh absolutely but in this
case it's a sex scandal it's a woman
speaking out against somebody in power
and they want to say it's just because
it's him but I would like to believe it
doesn't matter that it's him he just
happens to be the one now
off the break more extraordinary
Revelations from Stormy Daniels
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel nobody is
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
you were a registered Republican you
still are so for the Republican that's
my favorite you just made a whole bunch
of people watching this pee their pants
right because that just blows their
whole thing out there I mean a lot of
them probably don't realize I know you
could it's an easy thing to do have you
voted Republicans I have not in the last
election
did you vote for Trump in 2016. no you
didn't you never voted for him no I did
not but you have voted for Republican
before
and you never vote a Democrat
no I actually didn't I mean that was so
long ago that I didn't vote which is a
terrible thing to say but you know well
I do think people they'll be surprised I
know
I know and the whole reason that I
registered and got him I feel like I
feel like the movie they just keep
dragging me back in you know like I have
no political aspirations not interested
try not to be interested and it just
keeps happening you know like that's how
the whole bigger registered Republican
came about was because of the draft
stormy campaign in 2009 which I didn't
even know about and the only reason I
got involved is because I was mad at the
guy for using my name and pictures
without my permission
and I think you had a brilliant releases
when you ran against that and for the
Senate and you had a brilliant slogan
which was screwing people honestly also
true I mean I love that because that was
extremely pertinent to what we're now
talking about obviously
um the Republicans who have a problem
with you say that what you're doing is
deliberately trying to derail Donald
Trump's 2024 presidential campaign he
doesn't need my help for that
but does that even crossed your mind I
mean do you think you should be allowed
to run again
um it is a free country and what I'm
surprised at is that the laws allow him
to um as it stands now I was equally
surprised I was like oh surely someone
who's indicted and whatever would be
exempt from being able to run
shocker to me last week that that
there's no rule against it well you
could actually be convicted and go to
prison right and still be president of
the United States that's the most absurd
thing to me it plays My Mind actually me
too I was like wait what
um and that has nothing to do with him
he could just be dude a and dude you
know what I mean like that just seems
like
beyond my comprehension but I guess they
never thought they would have to
make that role Donald Trump pled not
guilty to all the charges he's always
denied having sex with you
but he's never explained why if that's
the case you ended up being paid 130 000
by his lawyer right there's a
an inconsistency best about that
position at best yeah I mean he's full
of Interest as he's like I mean I uh
somebody I should ask him that question
you know what I mean like
but it seems pretty obvious you know
what I mean like you have these people
that want to say that I was a prostitute
and paid that night so then I had this
whole other subsect I don't even know if
you know about this of sex workers and
escorts pissed at me for ruining
business really yeah for you know it's
like a doctor lawyer like client
privilege thing and I was like if that
had been the case I wouldn't have said
anything and if I was just trying to get
attention
I've had sex with some way hotter people
that are famous I would have told one of
those stories you know what I mean like
it wasn't a kiss and tell as a matter of
fact I took the money because I didn't
want anybody to know
um but there is that thing like if if
there was a transaction there was a rage
and that's what I went there for then
why was I paid over a decade later and
there's a couple things that as I've
been mulling this over
um
pretty obsessively in the last two weeks
like because it doesn't matter how many
times you put a fact out and you try to
tell people that they just
you know what I mean like if you want to
call me a name
fine that's your opinion if you think
I'm fat or whatever and I'm not going to
try to change your opinion about porn
whether you don't agree with it for
ethical moral well I'm not here to do
that I'm also not here to like change
your political opinions your stances on
something
but when you show a piece of evidence
that's
irrefutable and it's still just
you know I mean like hey I was Metro and
the golf course you know that event in
Tahoe in 2006.
I wasn't paid until a decade over a
decade later so how was that being paid
for sex
I mean yeah I mean that's ridiculous it
is ridiculous I'm going to come to the
to the meeting I actually have a
personal
involvement in one part of it which you
probably don't even know about oh really
I'll just hold that over until we get
there but it's quite interesting I have
so many questions well it was
interesting to me when I read it
[Laughter]
where were you when you heard he'd been
indicted it was last Thursday my book
was my birthday actually you know so I
was having a nice day and suddenly boom
right right everything like this bomb
goes off so where were you this is
this is great so he had put out that he
was going to be whatever and I even was
like he wouldn't know the day like he's
just he's up to something he always has
a plan so I didn't buy that one but my
attorney had said hey they want to talk
to you which we did it you know
um I think it was like on a Thursday or
Friday this is the DA's office right and
he said you know my attorney called me
he goes hey if you need to get on a
plane tomorrow and come and testify can
you do it I was like oh my gosh I'm
gonna have to scramble I have you know
things I need to take care of and make
sure my you know my child has child care
all this all the details that have to be
done and then I got a call not very long
later said no no it's not going to
happen so it kind of was a little
disappointing and then it was all quiet
it's like oh my gosh he actually is
going to get away with this again you
know what I mean and uh
so I kind of forgot about it
and I had my phone's on me all day you
know perusing no unusually quiet almost
and then I had put my phones down and I
went outside and I was riding my horse
and I could hear it going off and your
horse is called Redemption Redemption is
his name I can't make this up there's a
whole school Redemption right I'm
straddling a horse named Redemption when
he got indicted so when I get off and my
phone starts like Melton I was like what
you know my husband comes running out he
was like what just happened now my
phone's going off and then I you know
one of the missed calls I had was for my
attorney so obviously that was the first
one I I made and what did you feel in
that moment I mean what was your honest
feeling because it's interesting I saw
that your your lawyer uh tweeted about
it and you had an interesting sort of
double reaction I would say because you
said Thank you to a tweet from your
attorney Clark Brewster who said Trump's
indictment was no cause for joy and the
hard work and conscientiousness of the
grand jurors must be respected now that
truth and Justice Prevail right so that
was you were thanking so yes I I agree
with that then you tweeted later that
day thanks for all the support to
everyone and your love I have so many
messages coming here I can't respond
also don't want to spill my champagne
big smiley face hashtag teamstormy merch
autograph orders pouring in too thank
you for that
um
but it seemed to me that you and you've
alluded to this earlier that you had
kind of mixed emotions right so
certainly you were well you tell me how
how you what were your emotions when you
heard so I I like I said I I got off I'm
scrolling oh my God my horse is still
standing here like you know what's going
on so I was like oh my gosh I have to
finish taking care of you know
my animal and go inside and in the
meantime Clark had written that
tweet that message which was you know
very wonderful you know I was so caught
off guard he's like so I just retweeted
it and in the moment I believe you said
you know there's no cause of joy in that
moment
I was you know just ecstatic plus I've
got all these messages coming in oh my
God congrats to you know just you're on
that high for a minute and then
um
and that's where you know
I was like no calls for Joy this is what
I've been fighting for like you know
like it's moving forward finally there's
lighted in it so I was very excited and
happy because ultimately I mean and I
actually wasn't drinking champagne I'm
not allowed to drink champagne I get I
get white girl wasted it's not good it's
not a good look
but just to be clear the reason you
would feel so ecstatic is because it it
will possibly lead if this goes to trial
to you being Vindicated about telling
the truth exactly so of course he's
repeatedly called you a liar a lot of
people believe you've lied and this
would be the Vindication for you right
and that's really what's driving exactly
and so anybody would feel excited in
that moment but then hours went by and I
sat with it and started you know
reading and then I was like oh my gosh
bigger picture here is that
Clark was right there is no joy in the
fact that we had somebody in office that
had this much power to cause these you
know
Division and and
it he was right
but in the moment
yeah
off the break more extraordinary
Revelations from Stormy Daniels
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel note what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7 pm join me just do it well
that one two
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
the world exclusive interview with
Stormy Daniels
you very quickly began getting threats
and you've had these before ever since
this first right became to the public
Consciousness but you've got nasty
threats I mean your husband Barrett told
Vogue magazine there were threats going
to kill you you're going to kill your
family you're going to set fire to your
house I mean horrific things
what impact did that have on you so
I'm used to getting
horrible messages every day
um even before this just being an adult
Story I mean you're gonna get
um I will tell you that the first time
around back in 18
same thing like instant just flood it
and and how are you getting this on
social media or everywhere like
everywhere phone calls texts emails
people are calling you yeah so the first
time around it was mostly just liar
you know
stuff gold you know gold digger you sold
the story which you just made the story
up because he's president which now
we've proven that like everybody knew
about this from before anyway that was
the tone you know what I mean and I
would say out of
realistically probably one in a hundred
messages was included some sort of a
death threat you know what I mean
and they would always be from like an
account that somebody created just to do
that no followers hidden you know that
kind of thing now
it's different
it's
the tone is different I would say it's
one in ten now and intent a death threat
yeah and they are way more specific and
graphic and just instead of just some
battling person like you're gonna burn
in hell I uh that kind of thing they
seem to be more
serious I guess in a way
and they're not hiding
it used to be if you were they were
going to do something they would do it
from a blocked number or from a fake
Twitter account these people are using
their actual phone numbers and their
actual emails and their actual Twitter
accounts which then makes it worse
because they actually have followers
right and the first time around he was
already in office
you know what I mean like I there's
nothing I could really do to to hurt him
he was President of the United States
right what am I going to do he'd already
made gotten the nomination all that
stuff so this time around they think
that it could actually hurt and this
time around he got indicted he could not
become president you know a lot of
people you could stop him getting back
to the world right and whereas partially
be responsible for him you know go to
jail going to jail so there are a lot
more
passionate I guess that's a good word
enthusiastic uh with their threats and
they're not hiding and they sometimes
they genuinely feel
that they are doing something right that
they are the Patriots you know I told my
husband the best way to describe it is
before it was just like these rat like
loud mouth armchair anti-porn like
judgmental hypocritical
people you know faceless now they are
doing it
like like a suicide bomber they truly in
their steps but more importantly in the
depths of their soul they feel like they
are doing the right thing does that make
sense Barrett said storm is tough she's
pretty good at laughing things off but
it does get to her of course and it's
clear from the way you're talking about
this that the scale of what's come your
way in the last 10 days or so it's just
been horrific
and then I guess they said that like the
um
it's not even until next December I'm
like oh my gosh There Goes My Summer
right I won't be able to go anywhere but
it must have a massive impact on your
life on the way you conduct yourself
where you go of course you know I spent
the first you know the first go-around I
didn't even pee by myself for almost two
years you know and I'm pretty
independent I'm pretty tough you learn
all these things like
make sure when you go every single place
you go into you know where the exits are
um placements in restaurants where I sit
in the car like just like I never my
bodyguard's taught me and I don't even
know the reason for this honestly never
sit behind the driver you always sit
like all these little things that what
effect does that have on you and your
personality
um well I feel very
constricted and
like repressed almost I can't do the
things I want to do or if you feel
permanently agitated nervous of course
and you know your it makes you become
paranoid and anything you do or say can
be spun I'm going to come to when you
first met Donald Trump but do you wish
you'd never met him of course
I mean people say if you could go back
in time would you do it over
and say how far back does this time
machine go if I went back to 2016-18 or
whatever would I change what I did
sometimes In the Heat of the Moment I'm
like I wish I'd never yes but no I would
do it the same because I mean I would
take it back to 2000 it was the right
thing to do if I could go all the way
back to 2006. no if we could play
sliding doors yeah no can you meet him
get on the golf cart and dump in his
room or you don't meet him oh I
absolutely would not have absolutely you
know I was I was
told I was invited to dinner well let me
go through it so 2006 you're 27. he was
60. you were the biggest porn star in
the world you just appeared in Judd
Apatow's 40 year old virgin he said you
were a smart businesswoman he said you
should never be underestimated I mean he
was full of compliments Jonathan for you
we got Hollywood courting you for movies
he was the biggest TV star businessman
in the world and you meet right were you
a fan before you met him
um to be honest I didn't have like a
hard opinion one way or another I didn't
watch his shows you know obviously
definitely knew who he was he knew his
face did you like the sound of him or
not or was he because obviously he's
Frank Brad she's very arrogant yeah I
mean I wasn't a fan and I wasn't not a
fan right you know you're open-minded
yeah and I was aware
of course you know I I wasn't like oh my
God I can't yeah no and I also wasn't I
hate that guy it was just like oh this
is
he's figured out how to do some stuff he
must be
good at what he does he's an interesting
guy regardless of whatever you think oh
yeah absolutely absolutely you meet at
this Golf Tournament in Lake Tahoe in
California you've been hired to host a
gifting sweet stand oh no it gets better
than that
tell me you don't appreciate the irony
and hilarity of a adult film company
sponsoring a whole
on a golf course
I mean
I do appreciate that my whole life is a
freaking ethanol thing like you cannot
write this stuff right
so you led up to be one of the hostesses
for this gifting Suite Stone but also
the Greek competitors between the teas
and you ended up in a golf cart with
Donald Trump what are you talking about
you two honestly on that initial thing I
didn't get a word in it was me and the
owner of the company and two other girls
and you know it was a brief introduction
I do remember his hesitation when he's
like this is you know my contract girl
this this is my contract girl this is my
contract girl and director stormy and he
was like oh you also direct I was like
yeah he goes
you know I was like oh that's cool I
always like when they add director
um and so we we go on and another girl
there was definitely flirting with him
and Anna I wasn't interested
um I didn't even speak directly to him
other than a
nice to meet you and good luck your
round today or you know pleasantries
um it was at the gifting Suite later
and that's when you ask your number
right was he pretty direct
um no he had his bodyguard do it Keisha
yes
oh I know well Keith's been with him I
think
30 40 years maybe on and off I think he
I think he likes he likes Donald very
much but Keith was there yeah and you
get invited up to Donald Trump's Suite
which is at the top of the of the harah
resort and casino hotel but I wasn't
invited to his room I was invited to
have dinner to talk about a business
thing and this is oh this is one of
those other things that I didn't really
light bulb moment until this past week
why would you go to a hotel room of a
married man
oh my gosh
I get it and and justifiedly so people
when you say go to someone's hotel room
what do you think you think you open the
door and there's a bed and a dresser and
it's the size this is a huge penthouse
wait yeah yeah it was
a table and apartment right I
didn't even see the bedroom at all for
three hours not so I'm going to use the
restroom so it's not like I went to a
guy's hotel room and we sat on the bed
that would definitely be more beneficial
but you were not a naive woman did you
not assume that he might have ulterior I
did at the very beginning so I was
invited to dinner
um he said come up to the room and we'll
go down to one of the restaurants
whatever and I was a little bit early
and when I opened you know when I got
there he was in his pajamas and that's
when I was like oh hell no and I made
fun of him and he immediately changed
and was a perfect gentleman so you
actually said he would look like you
have yeah I made fun of him how did he
tell you that I asked him if Hugh Hefner
knew he stole his pajamas
knowing Donald Trump I suspect he didn't
find that very funny
um
I was early and he said he was running
late and then he's like excuse me go put
some clothes on and and that's what he
did and he came back and was
there was no more red flags after that
you have dinner in the suite because
there is a dining room so no we actually
he's
a dinner really I never got my dinner or
what did you think you
think you have a meaning about a
television show about Celebrity
Apprentice yes
so you had no dinner no no alcohol he
doesn't drink no do you drink a lot I
didn't at the time no
no so no alcohol no dinner no
no you discussed the adult entertainment
business he's quite intrigued by the
business oh yeah and I think in
particular how many royalties you made
yeah he asked the films
um we had a
pains me to say this we had a pretty
good
conversation it was you know at first he
was arrogant we all I mean we beat the
story to death he was very arrogant he
was pompous he was puffed up I was
unamused and starving
and finally that's when I snapped and
was like somebody's just spanking with
that magazine so because he kept showing
you a magazine it was a Money Magazine
with him on the couch right he just kept
talking about how these great things he
was doing and and all this stuff and you
eventually said I'm going to spank you
so somebody should have spank you with
eyes do you ever talk about anything but
yourself and he was who and he walked it
back and then there was another at least
two and a half to three hours where we
talked and it was a did you like him I
did I was not attracted to him no no ew
no
told you I was banging some hot
celebrities which ones were you I'm not
telling you that we can't just say I was
banging some hot celebrities not of
course take me to the water's edge not
giving me a drink still oh I just did
[Laughter]
it's the art of the tease my friend
um book title don't you steal that
um but I mean we talked to him but he
told me you know about his golf course
he was having some problems some
environmentalists and and we talked
about something uh some condos or
something he was building it's been a
long time I don't remember he asked me
about the adult business and you know do
we have health care of royalty it's like
business questions and at no point did I
feel like he was checking out or you
know it was a good conversation he was
like what do you want to do and then I
told him and he was like now the more I
think about it the more I think about it
my idea is great and so we talked more
about so who had the first mention of
The Apprentice yeah he did oh he did
absolutely it was his idea that would
have never crossed my mind because he'd
done the normal Apprentice for many
years very successfully and he was about
to launch Celebrity Apprentice right
actually based on a UK uh one-off
episode for charity which I took party
um and actually the series that he was
offering you in these conversations I
ended up taking part in that series and
I won it
that was a little bombshell I had for
you this is this is your fault you took
my part well you're assuming you would
have won you would have beaten me he
told me I was going to
do you think you would have beaten me
I don't know
to try
I think you'd have been a pretty good
competitor isn't it like a voting thing
uh what is audience voting no it's down
to him oh he fires some of them well
then I definitely want to beat you I got
a feeling that you you might but it
wouldn't have been Fair no it wouldn't
it be it wouldn't have been Fair he'd
have had another reason to to vote for
you
um you mocked his hair at one stage and
he said if he cut it he'd lose his power
like he was some sort of Samson right
this is great he asked me something he
goes uh
because I want to ask you a question and
and it's it might be it might be rude
you know why so I was gearing up for
some sort of like sex question or you
know what I mean like and it wasn't it
was it was a question about I think it
was how much we get paid
for a scene right
um and I was like oh
that's not offensive and I answered his
questions and explained the different
you know pay brackets and men versus
women and sex acts and whatever and he
was like oh and I was like I want to ask
you a question and it is offensive
and he goes okay I go
with the hair like you have to doubt and
then he you know he told me that um
because around the same time he was
doing something on one of the wrestling
things and the bet with Vince mcmah man
was like he lost he cut his hair I was
like what would you have done he goes oh
no no
it was never gonna happen he goes it's
kind of my trademark he goes That's the
big thing he's like I always have these
people want to give me a makeover and I
was like oh so this is this is a a
choice
he's like yeah I guess it's just it's my
it's my it's my trademark and and I was
like oh
like Samson and that's how that
conversation so you're having a good
business conversation absolutely you're
getting on well you like him you don't
have any sexual desire towards him but
then it all changes because you go to
the room he also in his defense okay did
I did that just come out of my mouth in
Donald Trump's defense I said that
didn't I you did say that okay
um he also
wasn't leering or flirting there was no
footsie under the table I mean when I
was talking to him he wasn't staring at
my you know what I mean like it didn't
it didn't feel creepy at all but then it
all changes
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
please
welcome back it was time for Stormy
Daniels to get personal
you went to the restroom when you come
out a little bit later he's now on the
bed and it's in thing about you've
always said it was all completely
consensual but you told Vogue magazine
in the last few days you gave an
interesting version of the event and I
wanted to read it to you and just get
you to clarify absolutely people have
made a lot of assumptions based on what
you said he said I'm standing there on
the door when all of a sudden he's there
in his underwear doing the world's worst
Burt Reynolds impression and that's the
thing I don't understand I don't
understand how I got from the doorway to
being underneath him in the bed I
remember thinking his bodyguard is right
outside that door what happens if I hit
him is that bodyguard going to come in
here and hurt me I remember him saying
do you want to go back to the trailer
park I never said I lived in a trailer
park I didn't I said we were poor I
don't remember taking off my shoes and
that's what gets me because these were
gold shoes with buckles kind of a pain
in the ass to put on takeoff you know
and I know I took them off because I had
to put them back on again and I remember
that putting them on and it being a
thing because I wanted to leave
afterwards I know I didn't say no she
adds but I also know I didn't say yes
right I wasn't threatened I don't know I
just don't know yeah even if you read my
book every detail I could tell you what
he had in his toiletry bag in the
bathroom because I dug through it
um like I can tell you the pro but
reading what you told voters and there's
this missing space right so people have
tried to sort of draw and then I would
like to read it I was not drugged people
like oh it must have been a real
absolutely no alcohol no drugs
absolutely not but do you believe it was
all consensual then or not
um it wasn't non-consensual and that
brings us kind of back to where we are
you know in the world now like does it
have to be a clear guess like are men
getting punished for things that
every time you make love to somebody or
go on a date do you have to have written
consent you know what I mean like people
are like oh you need to take
responsibility for going to this married
guy's hotel room while I've explained
the hotel room part and it wasn't to go
to his room we were supposed to go to
dinner and then we didn't but you're not
saying he forced himself no he did he
didn't physically come at me I mean I
could have taken him we both know that I
suspect that's true
um but I I did freeze but then you're in
this whole gray area of like
what constitutes consent and
non-conscience and I that is honestly to
be completely
truthful with you I am still
wrestling with buying for me my husband
had a long conversation the other night
about different scenarios and how the a
blanket
thing doesn't apply you know what I mean
it's just
and I was so terrified back then of
um not being taken serious or and then
people like well why did you go back and
see him multiple times because I didn't
want it to have been for nothing I just
made sure I was never alone with him
again
um so when it when it was over the sex
part you left quite soon after that oh
yeah within five minutes really four and
a half of which probably me trying to do
those damn little gold buckles and when
you left what were you feeling
uh nauseous like just mad at myself I
was in
I I was just like what what did I
misread you know what I mean and as a
woman especially from the south and back
then like there's this whole thing like
well
what is the word I'm looking for that
somehow it's our fault you know oh you
were asking for it was your skirts you
know that mentality so I just literally
like sat up and was replaying every like
what could I have done or said that was
misconstrued and then when I realized
absolutely nothing I was kind of a
honestly
um
what did I miss from him
nothing like I just you know what I mean
and my flow was blowing up obviously the
people who knew that I'd gone to dinner
wanted to know like where are you like
what happened like blah blah how many
people knew what had happened that night
no just generally in the next few weeks
months yeah 100 oh a lot of people yeah
that's the crazy thing like everybody
knew where I was going that night I was
with before I even went to his room one
two three four like seven people knew
where I was going
um afterwards everybody knew he called
weekly I'd put him on speakerphone in
front of my entire crew and it was not
it was not a secret and he met him a
number of times afterwards he went to
his office in New York and then I think
the following month he went to a party
here in L.A you went to a Miss USA
pageant and each time you met it I did
not meet him in person at the pageant
he's set up at the car service and the
tickets and everything but when you saw
him was it perfectly normal between you
I
you know
it made my skin crawl and I was just
very careful not to
be put in that situation again and he
definitely you know
thought that he definitely wanted to
revisit right um
I mean I can't even be mad at him for I
mean wouldn't you oh we've done this
before you know I'm not even upset about
that you asked him on that first night
about his wife Milani they didn't be
married quite recently she just given
birth to their son
what did you feel about that you've been
criticized for that part of it you've
already said that also why I didn't
think anything was going to happen
you know what I mean like why would I
assume that this person was going to be
half dressed and
outside a bathroom door when we had
talked about his daughter which people
tried to sexualize and it absolutely
wasn't yeah
um and he'd show me pictures of of his
wife and son
he did
and what did you feel about that oh
we're just talking about cutie was
nothing different than if I I don't know
if you have Victoria if we show pictures
right now of each other's kids like oh
look
look at the fit you know you said that
it was only when you had your own child
later that you began to feel a bit
differently about the whole thing
because you realize the reality perhaps
right but it
sharing a photos it was it was when
people do what they mean like I mean
someone tweeted you last week and said
why did you sleep with him even though
you knew he had a wife and you replied
why did he invite me to his room take
off his clothes and Corner me when I
came out of the bathroom even though he
knew he had a wife exactly
why is anyone
responsible for somebody else's behavior
in their marriage I didn't take a vow
and
to you know well as anybody it's
there's this whole thing like where you
blame the other woman but in the other
scenario you rarely blame the other guy
you know what I mean it's just somebody
tweeted you as well last week
I was like I bet I know what you're
gonna ask well they said president Trump
wouldn't touch you with a 10-foot pole
and he replied true he used a three-inch
one one of my finest moments yes
when you're sharp and Sassy on Twitter
and you'll probably exactly exactly like
him actually oh in the sense oh I'm
gonna Kanye you right now
here's what I meant on Twitter you take
no prisoners
no way better than
and you meet him at the Beverly Hills
Hotel in July 2007 when they're nearing
the end of the casting thing and you
know you've already met him a few times
since he stayed in touch by a phone yeah
and it was the same drone over and over
I think to answer your question in a
nutshell he was absolutely serious he
was absolutely genuine he meant it with
all of his heart I was also correct that
they would never let that happen I think
he knew sooner than he let on him and he
dragged it Ryan did he tell you at the
Beverly Hills Hotel that yeah you
weren't going to be in it no it was
later yes on a phone call
you didn't have sex with him when you
made him at the Beverly Hills Hotel why
not
because I didn't want to did he want to
of course of course yeah I pretend I
told him I was on my period And I had my
my then boyfriend outside
how did he react to that
you were busy his phone kept ringing and
and
you know then he just wanted to know how
long I was in town and when we could
meet up again I just kept but that was
the last time you spoke to him no the
first time I saw him did you speak to
him again many times for how long after
that
I want to say roughly three months for
three months yeah and then it stopped I
stopped banishing the phone did you why
because I one I knew that it wasn't
going to happen he he told me The
Apprentice right and you never spoke to
him again
after the break I asked Stormy Daniels
the question everybody wants to know
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
thank you
May 2011 so this is six years later you
finally agree to tell your story to In
Touch magazine right for fifteen
thousand dollars it was reported so is
that correct yes
why did you want to do it then okay so I
didn't
um I had just had a baby do you have
children I do okay so your your wife for
now nobody wants to be photographed or
fight or do anything when that has just
happened and you can't even stand up
straight and you look you know like you
just had a baby
and like I said the story was La
everybody knew hadn't talked about it in
years I am now married to someone who's
a little
said like emotional sense that we just
had a baby whatever and I got the call
that someone had
basically sold the story and Linkedin
they were sniffing around I have no
evidence of who that is I have a I'm 90
sure I know who it was I just can't
prove it so if you're careful what I say
um and I was like nope nope nope
absolutely not not interested and then
you know finally he comes back and
they're like well he's gonna you know
this person's gonna tell the story and
get paid unless you want to do it
instead
it's going to come out anyway would you
rather it be your version and you get
the money or this other person's version
and you get nothing and they've made
money off of you that's so you decided
to do it so I decided to do it and they
asked if I would take a lie detector
test I was gonna say you took a
polygraph and I said absolutely and I
passed and actually it was corroborated
the story by one of your good friends
and supported by your ex-husband both of
whom also passed right polygraph tests
so you've got three people who were
aware of the account you gave all of
whom passed polygraph tests which is
pretty compelling uh evidence but the
story never ran and two former employees
of In Touch magazine they just said it
didn't run because after they called
Donald Trump seeking comment right his
attorney Michael Cohen threatened to sue
them a lawyer yeah I'm not sure if it
was Cohen you were almost relieved even
oh absolutely even though you've taken
that decision to talk about it right
part of you was still like I don't know
well the only reason I took the decision
to talk about it was I was taking back
control because it was going to be
talked about anyway
just like I'm sitting here talking to
you instead of having you talk to a
friend of a friend you don't understand
that but you never got paid then no
because it never came out and then in
June 2015 Donald Trump announces he's
running for president
what is your reaction to that
eye roll
eye roller also a slight trepidation
nope not at all you didn't worry about
what had happened no because he had
straight up told me he never wanted to
be president
like he straight up told me that
really yes and he's like wow he's like
something you know some people want me
to become president and I was like he's
like why would I ever do that this is
way like all the reasons
I don't want to be president like why
would I it sounds like a terrible
freaking job you know what I mean and he
was like this is what I I don't need the
money I have this I have you know all
valid
points you just rolled your eyes you
just thought yeah I was just like do you
ever think he could win I I didn't even
think he was actually going to run I
thought it was another one of his
footstorming on The Apprentice or go on
WWE yeah of course why not
but he then wins the nomination looks
like he's heading to to potentially win
against Hillary Clinton then on October
the 7th of 2016 just before the election
this tape from Access Hollywood behind
the scenes tape dropped
and it was Infamous it included him
saying you can just do what you like
when you're famous a woman you can grab
them by the
you said recently this grabbed
back talking about yourself but when you
when you heard that tape what did you
think did you think as some people did
that he was genuinely meaning every word
of that that he was a sexual predator
who would do that to women or do you
think as he put it this was locker room
banter and that he meant really if
you're famous women gravitate around you
yes all the above it could have been
either
and probably a little bit of all the
above yeah
I mean
obviously he's gotten away with it so
what he was saying is partially truthful
do you think he got away with that with
you
yeah
but not anymore
you then go after this story breaks you
and your attorney Keith Davidson go to
the National Enquirer did you go to them
or did they come to you I don't know I
wasn't part of it
I never spoke to them
um but they say you're willing to go on
the record about having the effect this
is three weeks before the election right
keep in mind I have
all these people in my life hitting me
up
remembering because they had heard him
after the Access Hollywood tape drops
right hitting me up that you know knew
from back then a lot of people that I
work with are the same people that I'd
worked with before and they remember it
and and so now they're like you got to
do something so you thought again I can
get in and tell my story the way I want
to turn it
I gotta be honest with you I don't
remember if the word Inquirer was
straight mentioned to me I could be
wrong it was just a lot has happened
because the story is that the Inquirer
CEO in order to then contacted Michael
Cohen who then offered you a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars for the story
rights and for you to sign an NDA a
legally enforceable document written to
ensure the story won't actually ever be
made public so I kind of catch and kill
they call it right where the inquiries
Corporation because they had good
relationship with Donald Trump and
thought he might become president
so you agreed to this and you signed the
NDA and you accept this deal the
document didn't include Trump's
signature it had a space for it but he
hadn't signed it it was a separate
letter so why did you do the deal
so
two parts of that I wanted it to go away
I was told it was to not release the
story
there was catch and kill I didn't even
know that part I was told it wasn't
going to come out
um which is exactly what I wanted I
didn't want this coming out I had a
great life I was living in Texas
everything was great
it's last thing I wanted
um and then I had what you don't know
and I have talked about it it's in my
book but people just
um is that they're before that
um I have a friend that's an attorney
not my attorney
um that I'm just friends with
in Texas it was talking about how oh you
know he knew the story from way back
when I know you should say something
blah blah blah I was like he doesn't
even want to be president I was like I'm
sure he's not even he's it's some sort
of he's either In Cahoots with Hillary
remember he backed her before which
makes sense or there's something going
on here I'm not worried about it he was
like all right all right and then he got
the nomination and then he his whole
tone with me changed and he was like I'm
concerned I was like why he goes well
now as big of a doofus as he is now he's
still actually the Republican party's
problem
and they're gonna have to clean up his
mess and get rid of skeletons I wouldn't
be surprised if you died in a single car
accident or you OD'd I was like what
he's you're their problem now like think
about it think about what happens in
Maryland like all these people I was
like but then I was like I went down a
rabbit hole in Google what happened to
Marilyn Monroe I think he named a bunch
of other and I was like oh my gosh and
then they approached me with the NDA
and I was like what do you think I
should do and he goes well I think you
should come forward and stop him when he
goes but as your friends
at least if you sign this and there's
payment there's a paper trial and they
can't hurt you
and I was like that made sense it makes
absolute sense and he was like
he goes why you though he's like you
can't be the only woman I was like yeah
maybe because I'm the most famous so he
becomes president what are you feeling
that this guy that you had sex with he's
not the president of the United States
so I I leave him I was like
America just became a reality show see
how this goes you know what does he know
anything about being like
did you try and contact him or not no of
course not throw any of his prices oh
absolutely not
absolutely not in January 2018 so this
is the year after his inauguration The
Wall Street Journal reports on the deal
and Michael Cohen States publicly he
paid you using his own money he wasn't
directed to by Donald Trump
and you respond by suing Trump and Cohen
seeking to have the NDA invalidated
right but because he didn't sign it and
because he said he wouldn't enforce it
the case was dismissed and then things
start to spiral
And to clarify
because this is where people mess up all
the time the case dismissed in my favor
which means I was released from the NDA
right you were then I want to tell you a
story if you wanted to right it was no
longer valid I was released because he
hadn't signed anyone he hadn't signed it
and also they had broken it they had
broken the the stipulations in the NDA
not once not twice but three times
before I ever did
so you then issue a letter and this has
been very contentious oh here we go yes
this is one of those things I'm telling
you that people don't right so this is
in the same month that the story gets
reported by also Johnny you say to whom
it may concern over the past few weeks
I've been asked countless times to
comment on reports of an alleged sexual
relationship having Donald Trump many
many years ago the fact of the matter is
that each party to this alleged Affair
denied its existence in
2006-2011 2016 2017 and now again in
2018 I'm not denying this affair because
I was paid hush money as it's been
reported and overseas owned tabloids I'm
denying this affair because it never
happened I'll have no further comment on
this matter please feel free to check me
out on Instagram Stormy Daniels so
that's the second one right so explain
to me though that's the second one there
was one before that right so people
point to the contents of this letter and
they say well what changed I mean you
couldn't have been more categoric in
saying I was still under the NDA Michael
Cohen wrote that and had me sign it and
I didn't want to which is why I signed
my name wrong right before I went on
Kimmel and pointed it out how did you
sign your name
it doesn't it doesn't look like my
signature oh I see yeah but you were
still under the NDA so you felt obliged
to do this I was told if I didn't they'd
see me for the 20 million or whatever it
was
I had not been released from the NDA
people say and you know this because
it's been blazing around on Twitter in
the last week this is some new
um people say that it's new well they
say well this is the letter they say
this is not an approved Stormy Daniels
can't be trusted or believed what do you
say to those people I said I'm the only
one that can be believed because I was
the last one upholding the original
agreement I was the last one doing what
I was supposed to do
um also that's I never testified in
court that wasn't done under oath that
was printed off of an email that Cohen
said to somebody to send to somebody uh
it's not notarized it's not endorsed
it's not an affidavit it's not perjury
and I didn't break the NDA
because if I hadn't signed that I would
have broken the NDA
if you would if you had not denied it if
I had not done what they told me to do
if I'd come forward and
you know said the truth then I would
have been liable and I wouldn't have
been able to be released several months
later your then lawyer Michael avenatti
released a sketch of the guy we're not
going to get into him
released a sketch of the guy who
threatened you in Vegas and Donald Trump
tweeted a sketch years later about a
non-existent man a total con job playing
the fake news media for fools but they
know it
and in May the next month he tweeted
that he paid the money via Michael Cohen
because the agreement was used to stop
the false and extortionist accusations
made about her you about an affair
you then sued for defamation right
against Trump because he was accusing
you of inventing the Vegas incident with
this guy who threatened you even though
there were Witnesses and you know what I
mean like
that was this is this is the this is the
Crux of the whole thing for me is that
going back to that I sued to get
released from the NDA it was dismissed
in my favor
Trump owes my attorney attorney's fees I
won that so I did not break the NDA
um if anything I was the last one
standing holding it up
um then the defamation suit
Michael avenatti wanted to file that I
told him absolutely not no no no no
he goes why I go
I get called way worse things by the
minute he felt because you were a porn
star and he was President of the United
States you didn't have a chance of
winning it was unfair absolutely the
justice system failed me on that and is
that another reason why you felt
ecstatic when you heard you've been
indicted absolutely
repeatedly proven that of all things I
might be a but I'm an honest
like I'm the only one that has told the
truth the whole time Cohen went to
prison for it like we have
I'm gonna come to that uh on the 16th of
October 2018 so towards the end of that
year Trump tweeted a federal judge
throws out Stormy Daniels lawsuit versus
Trump Trump's entitled to full legal
fees great he says now I can go after
horse face and her third rate lawyer in
the great state of Texas please tell me
you're going to read one of my favorites
she will confirm a letter she's signed
she knows nothing about it a total calm
how did you feel about being called
horse face by the president of the
United States
I laughed
I laughed about you could say a lot of
things and by the way look I don't
actually look like a horse and if I did
I happen to love horses exactly they're
beautiful but
my response just sums up exactly like
like how do you
what did you say
oh gosh you don't have it it's so brave
it's basically like our president of the
United States ladies and gentlemen out
into the world he has a pension for
bestiality because this is a guy who
chased me for sex repeatedly and then
says I look like a horse face like
how do you talk about the looks of
someone that you were attracted to
without making yourself look bad I mean
it was hilarious but in the defamation
case because you lost you were ordered
to pay half a million dollars in legal
cost to Trump attorneys that was split
over the original case in the appeal and
you've just been ordered Yesterday by
Court here in California to pay another
hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
legal fees again over all that the
defamation case that's over six hundred
thousand dollars now how much have you
paid so far
um zero and some of that is offset I
don't know the exact numbers you'd have
to check it's all available he I've won
against him several times too so it's
that's not the accurate number because
the attorney cities I have won
take do you know in that case how much
no I have no idea you said I will go to
jail before I pay a penny absolutely
because the justice system failed me so
you're not going to pay it no even if it
means that you're held in contempt and
go to jail yep you're prepared to do
that yes
I didn't come this far to back down and
to give him money
I will say
that his attorneys however
or owed the money that you know what I
mean like they did a job
but your argument is he was calling you
a liar yes and actually he was the liar
yeah so why should you be paying money
for a case which in the end found for
someone that you believe was the one
telling the lies you said it better than
I did
but that's your position yes and I think
that it's accurate it's been proven over
and over that I wasn't lying like
Michael like I said Michael Cohen went
to prison and they're still like that's
like giving you know not the same degree
I'm not downplaying like a more serious
crime you know but it's like having to
pay your rapist for the sex
like what like I did nothing wrong but
stand up to him and prove that I wasn't
lying I'm not that's not fair
and I did have a legal defense fund but
Michael avenatti stole that too right
in May 2019 Cohen didn't go to prison uh
another woman it was then established
would have had a relationship with him
former Playboy model Carol McDougall so
she had a 10-month relationship with
Trump from 2006 to seven did you know
Karen have you have you met Karen do you
know her
um funny story no I didn't even know she
existed
um I don't even know if I really knew
her name maybe I knew there was a play
name Cara whatever she
Trump's a man he's a player man he had
me and Karen at the same vodka party and
introduced us and we shook hands what
yeah
the Trump vodka party in Hollywood I
went there with my friend Tara Patrick
and her husband he's introduced to you
yeah I shook hands with cameraman doodle
we had at the time you now know he was
having a relationship with her too
well that takes a brown snack exactly
what do you feel about that
honestly
kind of impressed
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no out with the people's
Channel note what are you every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it what that one too
thank you
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
foreign
politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
what's it like being a mother
um that's the one thing that was taken
for me that can never be given back was
time lost with with my daughter and I
get really upset about it that's what
affects me the most and I'll get
emotional and cry and then you know why
because she didn't ask for this you know
what I mean and there's things that I
missed because for a long period of time
the only way to keep her safe was to be
advertised to being somewhere else press
isn't going to show up and knock on the
door and chase her home you know if they
know I'm on stage in another city so I
stayed away a lot to protect her and it
worked
uh but at the same time
maybe somehow I've created a world
that's a little bit safer for her to
feel like
she could speak her voice one day if she
ever needs to what does she think of
what you've done she thinks I'm a hero
how does that make you feel
it might be
when my book first came out she was
small and obviously not privy to any of
the information inside but she was with
me
at a horse show and
my publicists arrived at the first
physical copy I was like how did you get
that and he walked up and he gave it to
me the front of my book it's dedicated
to her and she was sitting there and I
walked over I was like I showed it I was
like you can't read this for at least 10
years but read the first page
and she opened it and started crying and
yeah we'll do the first place it says
you know it's dedicated to my beautiful
daughter and she and she was very
emotional about that and then
um I said I'm I'm sorry that I don't get
to see you and she goes that's okay
Mommy I understand that there's other
little girls out there that need your
help more than I do right now wow from
like a seven-year-old and I was like
that's quite something
pleased
you married for the fourth time uh to
someone who'd also been in the adult
entertainment business Barrett blade was
his his name in the movies fourth time
lucky
what's up sir he's here
watching is the sex as good as we all
assume it must it's better
but that's to be good it's it's the
other stuff that is the the great thing
it's just um
it's easy
he understands you yeah and what he
doesn't understand he accepts and vice
versa what does he feel about Trump and
what's been going on I'm not going to
speak for him
what is the biggest misconception about
Stormy Daniels
um that I'm a liar
uh that
I you know I have nothing no other
talents but
you know laying on my back by the way I
do a lot of work kneeling and standing
as well thank you very much
um you know but I am a writer and
director and sustain of communion and as
a person what do you think your
strongest assets are in terms of values
what what do you think you stand for
um
being truthful like almost to a fault
giving people too many chances like
trying to find the good in people and I
have a hard time saying no when someone
needs something you know I will answer
the phone at three o'clock in the
morning I may not be the one to help you
change your tire but I'll make sure that
somebody gets oh I will pay somebody to
do it for you
um and you're tough clearly I mean
you've got guts yeah in your interview
with in touch all those years ago 12
years ago I should remember it they
asked if you had a message for Donald
Trump and you said karma will always
bite you in the ass
that staged pretty well that maybe I'll
name my next horse Karma what are your
feelings about him as you sit here
Donald Trump
like in what way like I don't I don't
hate him
you know what I mean like I I actually
it was funny you mentioned that I sat
with that maybe yesterday the day before
and you would assume I would
and and I probably used to and I used to
probably hate a lot of people like just
being you know all right whatever
but they don't really hate do you feel
sorry for him in a way
I don't really hate anyone and yeah in a
way I I do feel sorry for for him
um
it wouldn't surprise me if if it would
come out that he's been manipulated a
lot more than we than we think or that
based on the things that have happened
to me in the last five years things I
thought would never be possible
um
there could be something that we don't
know if he's watching this interview and
he probably is knowing him of course he
is what would you say to him
I don't know I'm so torn between me
and you know
um
don't get Lube in your eyes it'll be
part of it but like also still like just
tell the truth you know what I mean like
you do have a daughter you do
potentially have granddaughters and and
women you know and if you continue
to do this you were setting a precedent
where people think that they are
it won't be held accountable and there
will be I just I'm afraid there's going
to be a lot of people hurt
do you believe that this goes to trial
this particular case that you will be
completely Vindicated and that it will
be established you've told the truth and
he's lied
odds wishful thinking it will definitely
be a giant step closer in that direction
but I don't think it'll ever be 100
because there are some people that are
just
so steadfast to their beliefs they're so
unwilling to admit that they were wrong
or that he lies or that
you know they just they just can't let
it go they'll always be those still me
thank you very much thank you it's been
great to meet you nice to meet you thank
you you're a lot nicer than I was told
you were going to be
well that's it from me and Stormy
Daniels in Beverly Hills California an
extraordinary interview with a quite
extraordinary woman
Donald Trump when he met Stormy Daniels
was just a TV star and a billionaire
businessman but now after that one night
stand he faces the possibility of going
to a full criminal trial and if
convicted
potentially going to prison
a remarkable State of Affairs for him
and for the United States of America
that's it from me wherever you are
brother like stormy Keep It Uncensored
good night
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcast